[Music]
the cubicle is one of the more ironic
creations in the American office The
Adventure wanted to sort of save people
from the anonymous spaces that they were
confined to I think everyone knows the
images of what offices were like in the
early 20th century people have seen the
show Mad Men they know that steno pool
or if you've seen the movie the
apartment were just row after row of
desks surrounded by corridors of offices
and Robert Probst who is the inventor of
the office cubicle
he said the office of today is a
wasteland need to fix it effectively and
the solution that he came up with was
called the action office a three walled
space it was fabric wrapped wood and the
idea was to give workers a space of
their own something that they could
personalized you could hinge down to the
walls you can shape it the way you
needed so it was really meant to be
autonomous independent when it debuted
it was a real success people thought
this would totally change the way people
worked and it did just not quite in the
way that they intended
it started to become this tool for
companies to cram in as many people as
they could into as little space as
possible the cubicle occupies a very
strange place in in contemporary culture
I mean it's definitely one of the most
reviled objects in the workplace I mean
there's Dilbert with some office space
the cubicle is the symbol of this
uncaring stupid company basically we
have sort of a problem here
and so the fact that people have come to
hate the cubicle so much led to various
kinds of designs that get rid of
cubicles and this is seen as a kind of
liberation and I think open office plans
have a lot to offer in the sense that
they do offer interaction but studies
show that people prefer to work in
closed-door offices you find people who
are thrown out of Cuba those spaces you
move into more open spaces actually
missing their cubicles so it's another
kind of twist in the history of the
office